police investigating a shooting on the  northeast side of town we know at least  one person is dead madison kimbrough  joins us live from the scene with what  we know at this hour madison  we're currently on menden lane here in  the northeast part of the valley now  take a look as you can see that metro is  still very much on scene  we've been told by officials that one  man is dead after being shot  this happened around 2 45 today that man  died on scene now as of now  we don't have a description of the man  or know his age but there will be a  briefing by police very soon to give us  more information on the incident  we do know this is the fourth homicide  metro was dealt with this past weekend  alone  so keep it here on eight news now as we  will update you with the latest  information  as soon as it comes to us reporting live  madison kimbrough 8 news now